[Música]
el mundo conmemoró el día internacional
de la acción global por el aborto legal
miles de mujeres se tomaron las calles
de diferentes ciudades de américa
latina' para reclamar leyes que permitan
una interrupción segura del embarazo una
de cada ocho mujeres en el mundo muere
por abortos clandestinos vamos a
analizar este tema en unos minutos aquí
en france 24
el alto mando militar estadounidense
indicó que el grupo al qaeda podría
atacar a eeuu el próximo año esta
declaración tiene lugar durante su
defensa ante el senado de ese país por
el cuestionado retiro de las tropas de
afganistán tenemos un reporte desde la
ciudad de washington y el reino unido-
está listo para que su ejército comience
a suministrar combustibles en las
estaciones de servicio ante la escasez
por la falta de transportadores de
gasolina que son originarios de la unión
europea y que han abandonado las islas
británicas tras el éxito y la pandemia
de kobe 19
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 24 horas de
información desde nuestros estudios en
bogotá colombia soy santiago lópez
gonzález vamos a comenzar este
informativo de france 24 con una
actualización de la situación en la isla
española de la palma en donde la lava
del volcán cumbre vieja que está en
erupción desde hace unos 10 días
continuos ya llegó a aguas del atlántico
el choque de temperatura del magma con
la del agua genera una inmensa nube de
humo tóxico que podría alcanzar el
territorio del continente europeo y
también del continente africano según
los expertos podría llover esquirlas
previamente el gobierno de españa'
declaró la isla como zona de desastre y
también anunció un plan de ayuda para
paliar los daños materiales de la lava
que ha causado destrozos de viviendas de
cultivos y también en la infraestructura
de esa isla canarias
el tema central de la jornada son las
manifestaciones de miles de mujeres que
se tomaron las calles de diferentes
ciudades en la región de américa latina
en el marco del día de la acción global
por el aborto legal y seguro la
exigencia fue común para todas ellas las
participantes pidieron a los gobiernos
de sus respectivos países el acceso
seguro a esta práctica una de cada ocho
de las mujeres en el mundo muere a causa
de abortos ilegales en total en américa
latina' son llevados a cabo cerca de 4
millones de abortos al año la marcha que
tuvo lugar en la ciudad de santiago la
capital de chile fue la protagonista de
esta jornada dada que esta fecha
coincidió con la decisión de la cámara
de los diputados que aprobó la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
hasta las 14 semanas de gestación esto
representa un paso histórico para este
país suramericano
profundamente conservador y también
católico ahora sólo resta que lo discuta
el senado chileno para recibir la
aprobación definitiva que lleve a una
reforma en el código civil de ese país
para conversar sobre este tema está con
nosotros en y durán ella es miembro de
la comisión de articulación nacional de
la campaña nacional por el derecho al
aborto legal y seguro y también gratuito
en argentina es además activista de la
marea verde buenas noches bienvenida a
esta misión de france 24 y esta fecha
nos sirve para hacer un balance jenny
sobre la situación de la legislación a
nivel de la región de américa latina la
las garantías que tienen las mujeres en
sus derechos a decidir sobre sus cuerpos
para no para ejercer una maternidad
forzada digámoslo así como ve usted el
panorama en la región falta mucho para
hacer en términos legislativos
y qué tal la
canción latinoamericana la verdad que
venimos con fuertes luchas con
demostraciones del movimiento de mujeres
y del feminismo y muy elocuentes y no
solamente que tienen que ver con
justamente por velar por nuestra salud
sexual y reproductiva y no reproductiva
sino también con el tema de ejercer
mayores derechos justamente en el plano
de una latinoamérica que siempre ha
estado convulsionada políticamente y
además donde las desigualdades son muy
notorias y la verdad que el movimiento
de mujeres viene ampliando derechos y
bienes reformulando justamente los
marcos jurídicos y normativos para que
podamos ejercer justamente nuestro
derecho a decidir en libertad
y
todas las consecuencias a las cuales nos
lleva el labor y como bien decía antes
estamos justamente muy contentas por la
noticia con respecto a lo que viene
sucediendo en chile este que va a pasar
de nuevo a la comisión de mujeres en
proyecto y después se votaría en el
senado de chile bueno también con un
proceso político de democratización muy
fuerte muy importante con todo lo que
sucedió con respecto a la constitución
así que bueno en ese sentido el cono sur
que teniendo uruguay hacer todo aborto
legal desde hace muchos años ahora en
argentina desde hace poquito streep
jenny injustamente quería preguntarle
por el caso de uruguay de cuba argentina
guyana que son los líderes en la región
con la posibilidad de interrupción del
embarazo con plena libertad la
experiencia de estos países que ha
enseñado el uruguay lleva ya casi 7 años
con esta ley
completamente legalizado el aborto allí
cuál es la experiencia brevemente por
favor
la verdad que uruguay fue muy necesaria
todo todo todo lo que lo que han llevado
adelante porque justamente fue parte de
una escuela para para lo que sucedió
después en argentina todo lo que tiene
que ver con las mejoras en la salud
para las uruguayas bueno para todas las
personas que ejercen su derecho a sus
derechos sexuales y reproductivos fueron
muy necesarios y ustedes saben bien que
en argentina tuvimos un debate muy
profundo durante el 2018 donde muchos de
los aprendizajes que tuvieron que
tuvimos en uruguay fueron trasladados a
nuestro país todo lo que tiene que ver
con justamente la eliminación total de
las muertes maternas por abortos
clandestinos
el mayor el mayor número de embarazos
adolescentes
bueno todo eso tiene que ver justamente
con un proceso democratizador y de
información que se lleva así en la
sociedad en función de también no
solamente ejercer sino también
comprender entender e informarse sobre
nuestros derechos
a la vez que también hay un proceso de
la juventud muy muy interesante muy
importante en sí jenny pues le agradezco
mucho por haber compartido estas
impresiones con la audiencia de france
24 en américa latina muchas gracias por
haber estado con nosotros avanzamos con
otros temas destacados de la jornada en
haití fueron pospuestas para el 2022 y
sin una fecha concreta las elecciones
generales que estaban programadas para
el 7 de noviembre la decisión tiene
lugar después de que el primer ministro
haitiano ariel henry destituyera a los
integrantes del consejo electoral
provisional quienes serán fuertemente
criticados por la oposición del gobierno
por también favorecer al fallecido al
fallecido presidente juvenil moix el
primer ministro se comprometió a nombrar
un nuevo grupo de integrantes de este
órgano electoral tras una revisión de la
constitución del país y también convocar
a las elecciones
nos vamos ahora está ecuador allí un
amotinamiento carcelario en un centro
penitenciario en la ciudad de guayaquil
dejó al menos 24 reos fallecidos y otros
48 más heridos los hechos ocurrieron en
el penal más grande de la costa
ecuatoriana en el lugar fue desplegado
también un operativo policial y militar
para retomar el control de este lugar
luego después de prácticamente 5 horas
de violencia en el interior del penal
los enfrentamientos fueron provocados
por disputas entre bandas delictivas que
luchan por el control al interior de la
prisión varias armas blancas y también
algunos explosivos fueron encontrados
después de los enfrentamientos
seguimos en el continente americano el
alto mando militar de eeuu testificó
ante el comité de servicios armados del
senado en donde dio cuentas por la
retirada de las tropas de afganistán el
secretario de defensa de eeuu lloyd
austin defendió la forma en que se dio
esta salida no solamente de los
militares también añadió que conocían el
nivel de corrupción al interior de los
altos mandos de las fuerzas afganas no
son republicanos en el senado acusaron a
la administración del presidente by den
de incompetencia para conducir esta
retirada que le tomó 17 días la mayoría
de los demócratas afirman que la salida
apresurada se debe a la negociación que
realizó en su momento el expresidente
donald trump durante los diálogos que
sostuvo con el talibán que llevaron a
los acuerdos de doha en qatar
usted ayudamos a construir el estado
señor presidente pero no pudimos forjar
una nación el hecho de que el ejército
afgano que nosotros y nuestros socios
entrenamos simplemente se desvaneció en
muchos casos sin disparar un solo tiro
nos tomó a todos por sorpresa y ser con
esto afirmar lo contrario
necesitamos considerar algunas verdades
incómodas no comprendemos completamente
la profundidad de la corrupción y el
liderazgo deficiente en los rangos
superiores
bueno pues más temprano conversamos con
cristóbal vázquez nuestro corresponsal
en la ciudad de washington y nos dio más
detalles de esta audiencia en la que
también el alto mando militar
estadounidense dijo que el grupo al
qaeda podría atacar a eeuu el próximo
año una fuerte declaración escuchamos
martín me le dijo en el comité de
servicios armados del senado que solo
hubo consenso sobre el retiro de las
tropas de afganistán 10 días después de
que kabul cayera en manos de el talibán
es decir que tanto me leí como el
general del comando central que net
mckenzie consideraron la opción de
quedarse y pelear contra los talibanes
tras la caída de kabul sin embargo
mencionaron que no podían dejar solo a
2.500 soldados porque eso los dejaría en
clara desventaja y por ende quedarse
hubiera implicado el despliegue de miles
de tropas a afganistán y mantenerse en
guerra mile y cuestionó la estrategia de
joe biden de luchar la guerra contra el
terrorismo a la distancia porque hoy
perdieron toda la inteligencia que eeuu
tenía en terreno y les dijo además que
para poder seguir haciendo ataques
aéreos tenía que considerar hacerlo a
través de aliados como rusia y pakistán
frente a la polémica sobre sus
conversaciones con china en general 1000
y reveló que ha compartido información
sobre trompa 3 autor de libros recientes
y aclaró que tenía el visto bueno de
asesores del ex presidente para hablar
con los chinos mañana volverán al
congreso mark milligan & mckenzie el
secretario de defensa lloyd austin para
esta vez testificar ante el comité de
servicios armados pero de la cámara de
representantes seguimos en eeuu el
estado de florida en el sur de ese país
demandó al gobierno del presidente joe
biden por la política migratoria
conocida como atrapar y liberar con la
que se permite poner en libertad a
indocumentados que fueron detenidos tras
cruzar la frontera la fiscalía del
estado destacó que se trata de políticas
ilegales que causan daños a los
intereses del estado porque obliga a
gastar millones de dólares a su vez el
gobernador de florida el republicano ron
de santis solicitó que sean reinstaurada
las medidas migratorias impuestas en su
momento por el ex presidente donald
trump
vamos ahora hasta europa el reino unido-
allí hace frente a la escasez de
combustibles a la que se suma también la
falta de conductores extranjeros que
transporten los carburantes en camiones
a lo largo y ancho de las islas
británicas
los conductores han abandonado el país
después del break city y debido a la
pandemia de kobe 19 generando una
interrupción en la cadena de suministros
andrew amaya nos cuenta más en el
siguiente informe
los automóviles ambulancias y taxis de
londres se frenan por una escasez de
combustible que ha elevado los precios y
los conductores se muestran angustiados
es el caso de este taxista
el lunes no logré encontrar combustible
por suerte me quedaba la mitad del
tanque así que continué trabaje ayer
pero si la situación hoy sigue siendo
como la de ayer no voy a poder trabajar
sin combustible
y entre los británicos compran el
combustible en medio del pánico el
primer ministro boris johnson anunció
que el gobierno trabaja para retornar a
la normalidad
ahora estamos empezando a ver que la
situación mejora
los fabricantes nos han dicho que la
existencia están regresando normalmente
a las estaciones
insisto en que todos vuelvan a sus
actividades normales y que llenen el
tanque cuando realmente lo necesiten el
sector del transporte de mercancías en
reino unido- también siente la escasez
la falta de conductores de camiones como
consecuencia del break se intensifica la
crisis ralentizando el suministro de
combustibles y alimentos lo cual ha
aumentado los precios de bienes de
primera necesidad por ello el gobierno
británico propuso avisos de corto plazo
para conductores extranjeros sin embargo
la oferta no ha tenido suficiente
acogida
no gracias señor primer ministro no
aprovechar esta oportunidad no creo que
nadie quiera mudarse durante tres meses
solo para ayudar a los británicos a
arreglar su navidad
[Aplausos]
en estas circunstancias adversas johnson
llamo a los conductores del ejército
británico para que se preparen y sean
ellos quienes transporten el combustible
si fuera necesario es todo por el
momento en las noticias buenas noches
[Música]